l'actualité au cinéma les yeux d'elsa
c'est notre réouverture après huit
semaines de fermeture suite à un dégât
des eaux qui avaient abîmé la moquette
et les sièges de la salle
nous avons tourné toyer le haut la
moquette les sièges et on va pouvoir
vous accueillir dans un cinéma qui sent
le neuf pour récupérer les films qu'on
avait prévu de programmer qu'on vous
avait proposé puis qu'on a été obligé
d'annuler à cause de ce dégât des eaux
donc vous pourrez redécouvrir des films
sur grand écran comme les vieux
fourneaux première année mais aussi les
frères sister's de jacques audiard qui
est un vrai film fort à des grands films
de cette fin d'année 2010 8 jacques
audiard étant un des grands réalisateurs
français actuellement en activité
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille sur les
relations entre les hommes la fraternité
et cetera depuis regarde les hommes
tomber son premier film avec trintignant
et 4x
il n'a cessé de travailler cette matière
là des relations entre hommes de la
fraternité au sein de souvent d'histoire
assez difficile et assez complexe le
western semble lui aller très très bien
je vous invite donc à venir le découvrir
et puis on aura aussi sur la question de
la fraternité de manière plus concrète
et contemporaine et commémorative en
même temps les croix de bois
adapté du roman de raymond dorgelès
qu'on vous propose de découvrir en
version restaurée
le samedi 10 novembre à 16 heures et on
aura une petite un petit bonus en début
de projection de courts métrages
d'époque de 1915 je vous invite donc à
revenir au cinéma les yeux d'elsa nous
sommes réouvert à très bientôt
[Musique]